i am here with the dr guanche to break
down all the celebrity beauty trends of
2022. dr guanxi i got to ask you about a
new term i'm hearing the blood beauty
craze blood moisturizers well it is a
craze and it's platelet-rich plasma
where you dry your blood and spin it
down and then the plasma they get from
that has platelet-derived growth factors
so usually that's used in a procedure so
whether it's micro needling or laser it
will be something that augments collagen
but then you can get sent home with some
cream that has your own plasma in it
okay i've heard that the plasma in our
blood is liquid gold so how much does a
liquid gold moisturizer cost
well it can cost anywhere from a
thousand to two thousand dollars for
moisturizer for a month supply is that
worth it
well i really think the prp works best
with in conjunction with the procedure
so the follow-up cream is
plus minus well say i don't have a
couple grand to drop on moisturizers
what's a treatment that you recommend in
place of the blood moisturizers
microcurrent is very popular but now you
can do it at home a low grade
microcurrent treatment basically helps
to firm the skin but you have to be
really consistent and do it every night
for it to work gotta ask you about the
new beauty buzzword i'm also hearing
skinnimalism animalism is a play on the
term minimalism and basically it's using
power packed active ingredients that you
only use two or three items a day
rather than those ten steps
type skin care routine we are here for
easier skin care so we teamed up with dr
guanche and rockskin care for a look at
their newly formulated moisturizer i
love rocks new and improved retinol
correction max hydration cream because
it has two of my favorite ingredients
the retinol and the hyaluronic acid but
do we know it works in a clinical study
conducted on 33 women 97 percent had
visibly reduced lines within one week
okay this sounds good for my skin
emailism routine we know good skin care
can be expensive how much you can get it
at walmart for under 25 dollars
[Music]